so tell us a story about the the dad and
the son the Irish man in Calgary
oh my god I mean I'm on stage and I talk
about you know the bid I do about going
to a brothel in Thailand oh yeah a
woman's eating my butthole and all that
and I feel the bit and it's key crushes
and from the back of the room I see this
little leprechaun stand up he's wearing
green he's an eight year old Irishman I
can't do an Appy really wearing green
okay well I don't know about that it
could be one of those things things like
you know you you yeah in the Conor
McGregor and because you think that's
funny that's what he says and I go yeah
they laugh right and I go well do
[ __ ] lat
right people are laughing at this point
still yeah yeah and I go on so then I
don't have you guys seen my act but I do
a lap dance thing at the end and I
picked his nephew was like who like 22
year old kid Yeah right and I go I want
to show you funny did he volunteer or
you say course yeah he did volunteer but
there was a lot of people that
volunteered yeah and I still honed right
in on him the leprechaun fit and I go
leprechaun look right and I went so
sexual and I could see him get up and
walk out of the room and I I didn't go
out and greet anybody that show because
I don't want I've never fought a
leprechaun before you know oh my god it
was crazy
he got up and walked away I wonder if
nobody can you freaking know beat you
stop Kobe come here go B go B
[Music]